you do it in very interesting ways well
a first the first way is by taking the
story as it happens you know our
biographies happened one part at a time
there is a a sequence of events in our
lives and so there there's a a temporal
aspect to our experience there brings by
itself sense into the story in other
words you were not walking before you
were born and you were not doing x and y
before you did something else first
so there's the sequencing of events that
imposes a certain structure to the story
then there's something that intervenes
and is very important which has to do
with value value in the true biological
sense which is that contrary to what
many people seem to think taking it at
face value sorry for the pun we do not
give the same amount of emotional
significance to every event so there are
things in our lives that take up an
enormous importance and that become very
dominant effects in our biography and
that comes out of a variety of reasons
but fundamentally comes out of how that
particular experience connects with your
f effective systems of response so if
something produces an undue amount of
pleasure or undue amount of displeasure
it's going to be judged differently and
it's going to be introduced in your
narrative with a different size with the
different development and so that is the
the the next element to superimpose on
the sequencing element and in fact their
element is so powerful that very often
it can trump the sequencing event
that the sequency aspects so something
may have happened before and yet this
thing that happened just after maybe so
important that you don't even know about
the thing that happened before and when
you tell your story to yourself or to
someone else it's going to be told not
on the basis necessarily of the time
course but rather on the basis of how it
was valued by you in that value by the
way and does not need to be conscious
you know you're not designing haha this
is very good x-value no you're you're
assigning value naturally as life
unfolds and and that's this very
important element for the construction
of one's narrative and the other thing
that is very important is that
narratives are not fixed we change our
narratives we change our narratives for
ourselves and we change them not
necessarily deliberately in other words
some people do some people will
constantly reconstruct their biography
for external purposes it's a very
interesting political ploy you know but
whether we want to do it because we want
to have people to have a different idea
of who we are or not we do it naturally
so the way we construct our narrative
today is different from the way we
constructed it a year ago the
differences may be very smaller than
maybe huge and they're constantly
changing as a result of events that
happen in your life you're not the same
after say an incredible love affair that
went very well or a love affair that
went bad or something that happens to
your health or something that happened
to somebody else's health that is close
to you or something that happens
professionally all of those things sort
of rearrange the way your story gets
constructed
well it did of course it happens first
of all in the brain and and it's
affecting the brain because it sort of
changes the weights with which memories
are recalled so you know we we had a
chance of talking on another occasion
about the architecture of conversions
and diversions all of that is constantly
operating when you not only learn but
when you recall but as you recall in a
different light the weights with which
something is more probably going to be
or not recalled on the next instance are
going to be changed so you're constantly
changing the way Frank
Princeton synapses are going to fight
very easily or not so easily there's
that effect that is very physical very
down there at the synaptic level which
really means microscopic cellular level
but also molecular level because all of
those structures are operating on an
electrochemical basis and so that
changes there that are very important